Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. What's it really like transitioning from being a trainee psychologist to a fully
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。从实习心理学家转变为一名完全
qualified psychologist? Join me and Dr. David as we unpack the challenges, surprises and lessons in this pivotal career step. Whether you are an aspiring psychologist or perhaps preparing for qualified life, this is an episode you will not want to miss. Hi, welcome along to the award-winning podcast. I am Dr. Marianne and it's so lovely to have you here. I, as you may know, am a qualified clinical psychologist and there were many, many steps involved in getting me from where I started to being fully qualified and beyond. This felt like a timely and very important episode to record. If you find it useful, please do drop me a comment, a like. Consider sharing and subscribing.
合格的心理学家，真实的体验是怎样的？加入我和大卫博士（Dr. David）的对话，我们将一起探讨这一职业关键转折点上的挑战、惊喜和经验教训。无论你是立志成为心理学家，还是正在为获得从业资格做准备，这都是一期你不容错过的节目。嗨，欢迎收听这个屡获殊荣的播客。我是玛丽安博士，很高兴你能在这里。正如你可能知道的，我是一名合格的临床心理学家，从起步到完全获得资格及之后，我经历了许多许多步骤。我觉得现在录制这期节目非常及时且重要。如果你觉得有用，请给我留言、点赞，并考虑分享和订阅。
If you're listening on Spotify, please do rate. If you're on Apple Podcasts, please do take a moment to rate and review the show. And wherever you listen, please do take a moment to rate and review the show. And wherever you listen, please subscribe. This was an absolute gem of an episode to record, and I hope you really enjoy it. I will catch you on the other side. Hi, I just want to welcome along to the podcast, Dr. David Singleton. Hi, welcome along. Hi. Hi, Ryan. How are you? I'm really well, thank you. That's really kind of you to ask. Thank you for being here and for slossing us into your very busy, newly qualified schedule. But you've
如果你在 Spotify 上收听，请务必评分。如果你在 Apple Podcasts 上收听，也请花点时间为节目评分和评论。无论你在哪里收听，都请花点时间评分和评论。无论你在哪里收听，请务必订阅。这期节目的录制过程非常精彩，希望你喜欢。我们稍后见。嗨，我想欢迎大卫·辛格尔顿博士（Dr. David Singleton）来到播客。嗨，欢迎。嗨。嗨，瑞安。你好吗？我很好，谢谢。你问得真贴心。谢谢你来到这里，并从你非常忙碌、刚获得资格的日程中抽出时间。而且你
also had a fantastic summer as well, and we might think some more about that. But you are a very newly qualified clinical psychologist, which is going to be kind of our topic for today thinking about that transition and what qualified life is like. Yeah absolutely recently qualified at the end of September so it feels very very very new and into sort of spend time reflecting on that. Yeah absolutely and we're we're recording kind of mid-November at the moment, but this, you know, I think this is useful whatever time of the year it is for people. Just before we dive into all of that, could you give us a, you know, a potted history about you and why clinical psychology appealed to you? Yeah, absolutely. That's really interesting to reflect on that actually, because it feels like it's been such a long time.
度过了一个很棒的夏天，我们稍后可以再聊聊这个。但你是一位非常新晋的临床心理学家，这将是我们今天的话题，思考这种转变以及合格后的生活是什么样的。是的，绝对是，九月底刚获得资格，所以感觉非常非常新，还在花时间反思这一点。是的，绝对是。我们现在是在十一月中旬录制，但我认为无论一年中的什么时候，这对人们来说都是有用的。在深入探讨之前，你能给我们讲讲你的简要经历，以及为什么临床心理学吸引你吗？是的，绝对可以。反思这一点真的很有趣，因为感觉已经过去很久了。
But I actually, finishing sixth form, I feel there's always a big pressure of what to do at uni and at that point I definitely had no idea so I took a few years out I only intended to take one year and completely forgot to apply for uni the next but then within that two year time I was like oh I'm really interested I'd started to notice people around me and I was being really aware of maybe what sort of things might change the behaviors and what was I having to do to adapt what I sort of wanted to try and sort of work around people so I applied for psychology actually applied for neuropsychology quickly realized the neuro bit was a bit bit not how my brain was working but I loved the psychology aspect of it so I did my three years
但我实际上在完成高中学业后，觉得在大学选专业时压力很大，当时我完全没有头绪，所以我休学了几年。我本来只打算休学一年，结果完全忘了申请下一年的大学，但在那两年里，我发现自己真的很感兴趣。我开始注意到周围的人，并意识到是什么在改变人们的行为，我需要做些什么来适应，我想尝试在人们周围工作，所以我申请了心理学，实际上申请的是神经心理学，很快意识到神经科学部分不太适合我的大脑运作方式，但我喜欢心理学方面的内容，所以我读了三年，
and then I applied for a master's and moved down to London to do that and it was in clinical mental health because I hadn't had it for all the best intentions I couldn't get any work experience whilst on the undergrad and I came to London got on this master's course that gave me a placement and it was with an adult rehabilitation center and one of the ones in north london and really enjoyed it got a job as a part-time job within three months which was crazy which was working in a hospital and i didn't expect to get a job straight away but it was really nice i worked in cams and it it was eating disorders and really landed on my feet there absolutely fell in love with working with kids and I thought this is a really really difficult area but it was great to actually work with the clinical psychologist
然后我申请了硕士学位，搬到伦敦去读，专业是临床心理健康。因为我之前没有机会，尽管有最好的意愿，但在本科期间我无法获得任何工作经验。我来到伦敦，进入了这个硕士课程，它提供了一个实习机会，是在北伦敦的一家成人康复中心，我真的很喜欢。三个月内我就找到了一份兼职工作，这太疯狂了，是在一家医院工作。我没指望马上能找到工作，但这真的很棒。我在儿童与青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）工作，那是关于饮食失调的，我在那里如鱼得水。我完全爱上了与孩子们一起工作，我想这是一个非常非常困难的领域，但能与临床心理学家、
the psychiatrist the family therapist and really really enjoyed that and it was through being on there that a lot of the support workers were going on to the clinical psychology route so we'd sit and talk and find out what that might be and after three years I then thought right I need a bit more of a different experience so I moved on to work for talking therapies and trained as a PWP and really enjoyed actually the sort of the assessment and the and the therapeutic work that you thought i was doing and i just really found that i really wanted to connect and work with people i wanted to then think about what i could do in the doctorate and what other experiences i wanted to actually have so i always found that it was something i really wanted to
精神科医生、家庭治疗师一起工作真的很棒，我非常享受。正是通过在那里工作，很多支持人员都走上了临床心理学的道路，所以我们会坐下来交谈，了解那是什么样的。三年后，我想，好吧，我需要更多不同的经验，所以我转去从事谈话疗法，并接受了心理健康从业者（PWP）的培训，我真的很喜欢我所做的评估和治疗工作。我发现我真的很想与人建立联系并一起工作，我想考虑在博士阶段能做什么，以及我还想获得哪些其他经验。所以我总是发现，这是我一直想要
really strive to get those placements and we can get that varied work and figure out which which area do I want to work in and it was only the fourth time of applying that I got on so I didn't have to wait a few years which quite used to rejection now which is quite an interesting thing but fell in love on the course with health psychology which was not an area I thought that I would necessarily go into. And I'm just really grateful of all the opportunities that I've had. Oh, David, that's like your winner's speech. That's like beautiful, like so nice. And, you know, I kind of like that you said I only applied four times.
努力争取那些实习机会，我们可以获得多样化的工作，并找出我想在哪个领域工作。我是第四次申请才被录取的，所以我不得不等待几年，现在我已经习惯了拒绝，这真是一件有趣的事情。但在课程中，我爱上了健康心理学，这不是我原以为会进入的领域。我真的很感激我所拥有的所有机会。哦，大卫，这就像你的获奖感言。太美了，太好了。而且，我挺喜欢你说“我只申请了四次”。
Like you still feel like you won a prize, like only four times. Whereas for many people, they might stop at two or three and be like oh it's not for me but you were like yeah just it's obviously not my time I'm not ready for that yet but I when I get there it's gonna be fabulous and I think that's exactly how I felt really you know I'm envisioning this batch that said you know Dr Marianne you know and I'm not stopping till I get there well I envisaged the trainee clinical psychologist and you know and I'm not stopping until I get there well I envisaged the trainee clinical psychologist
就像你仍然觉得你赢得了奖项一样，才四次。而对许多人来说，他们可能在两次或三次后就停下来，觉得“哦，这不适合我”。但你当时想的是“是的，显然现在还不是时候，我还没准备好，但当我到达那里时，一切都会很棒”。我想我当时的感觉正是如此，你知道，我设想过那个写着“玛丽安博士”的徽章，我不达目的誓不罢休。好吧，我设想的是实习临床心理学家，你知道，我不达目的誓不罢休。好吧，我设想的是实习临床心理学家，
and you know actualized that really you know it wasn't going to be another way for me like it's that's what I was doing and sounds like you really felt similarly I think I did and I think I was always looking and trying not to have just all eggs in one basket so I was thinking of alternative ways because I thought I'm I didn't want to be doing this like 10 years later still applying because I would have felt oh dear I'm it's clearly not meant for me at that point but I mean I know people who've been applying seven eight times and got on so I know it's not unusual and sometimes it can feel like what more can I do but I was quite thinking I did want the clinical cycle do that's what I was aiming for but I
并且真正实现了它，你知道，对我来说没有别的路可走，这就是我要做的。听起来你也有同样的感觉。我想是的，而且我总是试图不把所有鸡蛋放在一个篮子里，所以我考虑了替代方案，因为我想，我不想在10年后还在申请，因为那样我会觉得“天哪，显然这不适合我”。但我知道有人申请了七八次才被录取，所以我知道这并不罕见，有时会让人觉得“我还能做什么？”但我确实想要临床心理学，那是我的目标，但我
I was starting to get like little backup plans of maybe what else could I do? If this isn't going to work in my favor, what can I go for? But the goal still, the ultimate goal was to still get on. Absolutely. And I think if it is taking seven or eight times, I think if people are like in that position now, I think it's important that you look at whether you've got kind of varied clinical experience relevant clinical experience ideally supervision by a qualified HCPC psychologist that you've got some research but if you still got all of that and it's not it's not working I think often what people are lacking is is their reflection and their ability to kind of really just transform answers you know and just like wow wow like that's my
开始制定一些备用计划，比如我还能做什么？如果这不顺利，我能去争取什么？但目标仍然是，最终目标仍然是进入这个领域。绝对是。而且我认为如果已经申请了七八次，如果人们现在处于那种境地，我认为重要的是要看看你是否拥有多样化的临床经验、相关的临床经验，最好是由合格的 HCPC 心理学家进行督导，你是否有一些研究成果。但如果你已经拥有了所有这些，却还是不行，我认为人们往往缺乏的是反思能力，以及真正转化答案的能力。你知道，就像……哇，这就是我的
experience anyway and I think often it is it's about how you write your statements and I'm the first to admit that my first couple of statements that I wrote I looked back and I thought no wonder I didn't get anything no wonder I wasn't called back. I mean, I did actually have interviews, one each year, but I did think, well, that's not written very well. I'm almost bullet pointing it and not really, this isn't going to be a formula that's going to work. I need to revisit this.
经验。无论如何，我认为这通常与你如何撰写陈述有关。我第一个承认，我写的最初几份陈述，回过头来看，我想“难怪我没得到任何回应，难怪我没被叫去面试”。我的意思是，我确实参加过面试，每年一次，但我确实认为，写得不太好。我几乎是在列要点，而不是真正地……这不是一个有效的公式。我需要重新审视这一点。
And then it was like speaking with, like you said, a HCPC, clinical psychologist, getting advice getting some tips really trying to think about how i still make it me but how i can sort of improve it and improve my chances and hopefully that did work absolutely and i think if you look at the form and you're completely daunted by it and you don't know where to begin it's maybe a sign that maybe it's not quite your time just yet because it should kind of be comfortably within your wheelhouse I think that's my take on it anyway absolutely and I actually pulled an application the year before my first one my my friends around me who were also in that sort of
然后就像你说的，与 HCPC 临床心理学家交谈，获取建议，获取一些技巧，真正尝试思考如何保持自我，同时又能改进它，提高我的机会。希望这确实奏效了。绝对是。而且我认为如果你看着申请表，完全被它吓倒了，不知道从哪里开始，这可能是一个信号，说明现在可能还不是你的时机，因为它应该是在你的能力范围内。我想这就是我的看法。绝对是。实际上，在我第一次申请的前一年，我撤回了申请。我周围的朋友，那些也在那个
world and the supervisor at the time really wanted me to go for it and I just in the end I just like I'm not ready so I just didn't do it and that felt right for me and whilst I may have felt ready at the time in the first couple of applications I look back and I think actually I'm really grateful I didn't get on because actually I think I wouldn't have been ready and the time that I got on I did want it I wasn't overly thinking about it all the time so it felt a really nice bonus but I felt really ready and I'd gathered I'd gained so much more experience in clinical and research work that it felt the right time and so I was really pleased that actually it was the fourth time which is strange
世界里的人，以及当时的督导，真的希望我去申请，但我最后觉得“我还没准备好”，所以我就没做。这对我来说感觉是对的。虽然我在最初几次申请时可能觉得准备好了，但回过头来看，我真的很感激我没有被录取，因为实际上我觉得我当时还没准备好。在我被录取的时候，我确实想要它，我并没有一直过度思考它，所以这感觉像是一个非常好的奖励，但我感觉真的准备好了，而且我在临床和研究工作中获得了更多的经验，所以感觉是合适的时机。所以我真的很高兴实际上是第四次才成功，这很奇怪，
saying it like you you want to get on the first time but actually reflecting back it was right that I got on that fourth year absolutely you don't want to be the least qualified least ready person on your cohort because that's just not that's just not where you want to be so I've spoken on the podcast before that I actually originally went to uni to do forensic science and in those first weeks I was just crying every evening because I hated it because it was such a steep learning curve for me and I just thought this is not how I want to be originally I was gonna do psychology and then had my head turned by forensics and you can make you know make choices to put things right again so I transferred to psychology and as they say the rest
说得好像你第一次就想成功一样，但实际上反思一下，第四年才成功是正确的。绝对是，你不想成为你那届学生中资历最浅、准备最不充分的人，因为那绝对不是你想要的位置。我之前在播客上说过，我最初去大学是读法医科学的，在最初的几周里，我每天晚上都在哭，因为我讨厌它，因为对我来说学习曲线太陡峭了，我只是觉得这不是我想要的状态。我最初打算读心理学，然后被法医吸引了，你可以做出选择来纠正错误，所以我转到了心理学，正如他们所说，剩下的
is history it's nice to actually look back at our different journeys actually and I really really enjoy I've got different friends in different psychology sessions and I really really enjoy I've got different friends in different psychology sessions and it's really nice just to see how different interests go in different ways and it's just finding that way and almost trying to reduce the pressure of I must do this way when actually it's really nice to have a flexible sort of mindset of being like you know what I'll try it and if it's not for me maybe what other area is going to be for me and you want to be for me I always wanted to work somewhere in a setting that I enjoy coming to work I didn't want to feel like they said almost tearful or like just questioning things all the time I actually wanted to be enjoying it and that
就是历史了。回顾我们不同的旅程其实很不错，我真的很享受。我有不同心理学领域的朋友，我真的很享受看到不同的兴趣如何走向不同的方向。这只是找到那条路，几乎是试图减少“我必须这样做”的压力，而实际上拥有灵活的心态会很好，比如“你知道吗，我会尝试一下，如果这不适合我，也许还有什么其他领域适合我”。我一直想在自己喜欢去工作的环境中工作。我不想感觉像他们说的那样，几乎要流泪，或者一直质疑事情。我实际上想享受它，而这
was the main sort of purpose why I think one of the main purposes again that I went for the clinical room absolutely you know we all because we're human sometimes have days where you think i'd rather just sit and watch netflix today or i'd rather go and sit in a coffee shop and watch the world go by of course that's normal but actually i swear guides on our brownies on i did them both when i'm at work there's nowhere else i'd probably rather be like i love what i do and as soon as i'm with clients and doing what i do you know obviously i love my children i love holidays like i love all that but it doesn't feel like it's an it's an effort or it's an endurance does that make sense it does and you know i think there are definitely days that even when you're
是我选择临床心理学道路的主要目的之一。绝对是，你知道，我们都是人，有时会有想“我今天宁愿坐着看 Netflix”或者“我宁愿去咖啡店看世界流逝”的日子，当然这很正常。但实际上，我发誓……我在工作时，我可能不想去别的地方。我热爱我的工作，一旦我和客户在一起，做我该做的事，你知道，显然我爱我的孩子们，我爱假期，我爱所有这些，但这感觉不像是一种努力或忍耐，这有意义吗？有意义，而且你知道，我认为肯定有几天，即使当你
working that you think oh my god i i i i've not got the skills and i'm not ready for this oh they they know that i'm not ready they know but actually ultimately that's a bad day and it's okay to have a bad day and it's okay to acknowledge that you're having a bad day rather than trying to be like no no no no it's okay but like you said for the last year when I've been working in Maggie's in a different centre it's the first time really where I really enjoyed looking forward to coming into work and being there and doing the work and yes the work that I do is really very emotional but I love actually being here and it's transitioned into this this newly qualified role that I'm in now I absolutely just look forward to coming in
工作时，你会想“天哪，我没有技能，我还没准备好，他们知道我没准备好”。但实际上，归根结底，那只是糟糕的一天，有糟糕的一天没关系，承认自己度过了糟糕的一天，而不是试图说“不不不，没关系”，这没关系。但就像你说的，过去一年我在玛吉中心（Maggie's）不同的中心工作，这是我第一次真正期待去上班，在那里工作。是的，我所做的工作确实非常情绪化，但我真的很喜欢在这里。它过渡到了我现在这个刚获得资格的角色，我绝对只是期待着去上班，
and that's what I'd always hoped for in a career of having that excitement coming to work. Oh that's so powerful so powerful I love that and some of our conversations have been on camera some of them have been off camera so I know that you did a trainee placement in the same organisation in your final year or during training. I don't know if it was your final year, but actually when this qualified role came up and you already knew you were going to be moving for the course, you were like super excited so I don't think I'd ever heard of Maggie's but could you tell us a little bit about the organization and how clinical psychology fits into the organization? Yes absolutely it'd be really really nice to think about that so I actually hadn't heard of Maggie's either until I was looking at placements and I had done my second year placement in a neuropsychology setting and worked with my supervisor in that
这就是我一直希望在职业生涯中拥有的那种去上班的兴奋感。哦，那太有力量了，太有力量了，我喜欢这一点。我们的一些对话是在镜头前进行的，一些是在镜头外，所以我知道你在培训期间的最后一年在同一个组织做过实习。我不知道是不是最后一年，但实际上当这个合格的角色出现时，你已经知道你要为课程搬家了，你当时超级兴奋。所以我认为我从未听说过玛吉中心，你能告诉我们一点关于这个组织以及临床心理学如何融入其中的吗？是的，绝对可以，思考这个问题真的很好。实际上，在寻找实习机会之前，我也没听说过玛吉中心。我在第二年的实习是在神经心理学环境中，并与我的督导一起工作。
placement. She wasn't my supervisor then, but I'd worked with her and she'd left to go to Maggie's. And as soon as I saw her name pop up, I was like, I loved working with her. Let's go and see what Maggie's is. And went to see it. And, you know, I walked in and I'd not even been there five minutes and I was like, oh, I want my final year placement to be here. This is a compassionate place to be, which I know is going to be one hell of a stressful year. And this is where I would like to be in that space, feeling contained, feeling supported, challenging work, but going to be meaningful. So Maggie's is a cancer support charity. It was, well, the first centre opened back in 1996 and I think back in 1994 is when they really started planning. There wasn't anywhere to actually be outside of this clinical hospital environment where she could get emotional support. Just someone to listen, someone to talk to in a really nice relaxing environment that wasn't a hospital corridor with neon lights everywhere.
她当时不是我的督导，但我曾与她共事，她后来离开了去了玛吉中心。我一看到她的名字出现，我就想，我喜欢和她一起工作。去看看玛吉中心是什么吧。我去看了。你知道，我走进去，还没待够五分钟，我就想，我希望我的最后一年实习在这里。这是一个充满同情心的地方，我知道这将是压力巨大的一年。这就是我想要待的空间，感到被包容、被支持，工作具有挑战性，但会很有意义。所以玛吉中心是一家癌症支持慈善机构。它……好吧，第一个中心于1996年开放，我想1994年是他们真正开始规划的时候。在临床医院环境之外，没有地方可以获得情感支持。只是有人倾听，有人在非常舒适放松的环境中交谈，而不是到处都是霓虹灯的医院走廊。
With medical professionals who were so busy but just couldn't have the time to just spend those extra minutes just to be able to talk to people about their experiences and with their families and friends as well and it was through that and her and her nurse and her husband that they started to think about what could this place look like and so the first sadly Maggie passed away the year before the first centre opened and since 1996 it's just developed and developed and it's now there's 24 centres up and down the UK, four internationally with goals and aims to really just get more and more of these many centres up and down the country or the May Cancer Hospital sites. And at Maggie's you can come in at the really friendly environments very homely very cozy the hospital we link very closely with the hospitals and the oncology department to try and build and keep those networks and connections because we know the NHS staff are so overworked
有太忙而无法抽出额外几分钟与人们谈论他们的经历以及他们的家人和朋友的医务人员。正是通过她、她的护士和她的丈夫，他们开始思考这个地方可以是什么样子。所以第一个……遗憾的是，玛吉在第一个中心开放的前一年去世了。自1996年以来，它不断发展，现在在英国各地有24个中心，国际上有4个，目标和宗旨是真正让全国更多的这些小型中心在癌症医院站点附近建立起来。在玛吉中心，你可以进入非常友好的环境，非常温馨、舒适。我们与医院和肿瘤科联系非常紧密，试图建立和保持这些网络和联系，因为我们知道 NHS 的员工太劳累了，
there's under resources that the pressure is so much there that we want to be able to work alongside them and so people come in to Maggie's it can be anyone affected by cancer either the person who's experiencing or family or friends and they can come in and just be greeted and welcomed into the centre make yourself at home here let's have a cup of tea have a cup of coffee have some biscuits or some fruit and we have cancer support specialists who will sit down and talk to visitors and just get to know them if they've got any questions welcome to them to the centers show them what we have sort of offer in a program that might be really helpful encouraging
资源不足，压力太大了，所以我们希望能够与他们并肩工作。人们来到玛吉中心，可以是任何受癌症影响的人，无论是患者本人，还是家人或朋友。他们可以进来，受到问候和欢迎，“在这里请自便，喝杯茶、喝杯咖啡，吃点饼干或水果”。我们有癌症支持专家，他们会坐下来与访客交谈，了解他们，如果他们有任何问题，欢迎他们来到中心，向他们展示我们提供的项目，这些项目可能非常有帮助，鼓励
people to come back and they can be there for they're really skilled clinicians they can be nursing backgrounds they can be radiographers, occupational therapists, often always work within hospital settings, and they know the links with the services. But what we also offer is financial support, and we have benefits advisors, but any questions that we might have in terms of what somebody might be entitled to, any sort of difficulties with
人们回来。他们是技术娴熟的临床医生，他们可能有护理背景，可能是放射技师、职业治疗师，通常总是在医院环境中工作，他们了解与服务的联系。但我们也提供经济支持，我们有福利顾问，但关于某人可能有权获得什么，任何类型的困难，
any sort of housings of lots of advice that you can get but then if someone is really struggling with their mental health and their and their cancer diagnosis then if the cancer support specialist feel that it would be really helpful to have some more further support that's when we when clinical psychology comes in and it's not just clinical psychology actually we have counselling psychologists as well and we offer that space to have one-to-ones the people but we also can offer couples work we can offer group workshops as either standalone ones or a course on various different topics of what the people within our areas and our communities are saying that they're really struggling with and tailor that to them.
任何类型的住房，你可以获得很多建议。但如果有人在心理健康和癌症诊断方面确实在挣扎，那么如果癌症支持专家觉得获得进一步的支持会非常有帮助，那就是临床心理学介入的时候了。实际上不仅仅是临床心理学，我们也有咨询心理学家，我们为人们提供一对一的空间，但我们也可以提供夫妻工作，我们可以提供小组研讨会，作为独立的研讨会或关于我们地区和社区人们说他们正在挣扎的各种不同主题的课程，并为他们量身定制。
And we just want to be part of that experience. So you come and see us when you need us. In terms of just being able to pop into the center, a lot of it is drop in. Of course, psychology, we do have appointment. So we do see people within our timetable. But it's one of those things where you can come and use us for however long you need. If you don't need us at any other point, that's great. But when you need us again, you just come through the door.
我们只是想成为那种体验的一部分。所以当你需要我们时，就来见我们。就能够直接进入中心而言，很多是随到随办的。当然，心理学方面，我们确实有预约。所以我们确实在我们的时间表内看人。但这是一种你可以根据需要使用我们多久的事情。如果你在其他任何时候都不需要我们，那很好。但当你再次需要我们时，你只需走进门。
Come and see us. Come and speak to us and have that emotional and psychology support as well as all the practical support as well. Fabulous. I think it would be a wonderful idea to invite you back on and we'll really think about working in cancer services psychologically. So that might be a really interesting future episode. Sounds like a lovely, lovely place.
来见我们。来和我们交谈，获得情感和心理支持，以及所有的实际支持。太棒了。我认为邀请你回来，真正思考在癌症服务中进行心理学工作是一个绝妙的主意。所以这可能是一个非常有趣的未来话题。听起来是一个非常非常好的地方。
And I loved hearing you say that actually you recognised that that was going to be a really compassionate space to help you transition during your final year of training. Could you talk us around your awareness of becoming qualified and moving into a band seven role? Yeah, I mean, wow. It really sort of, you don't really think about it on the course until you're starting to realise that you're working through your final year.
我很高兴听到你说，你实际上认识到那将是一个非常有同情心的空间，可以帮助你在培训的最后一年过渡。你能谈谈你对获得资格并进入七级（Band 7）角色的认识吗？是的，我的意思是，哇。它真的……你在课程中并没有真正考虑它，直到你开始意识到你正在度过最后一年。
Even when I picked the placement, which was in second year, and I knew that it was going to be my final one, it hadn't hit me in terms of the transition and that it was going to be my final one it hadn't hit me in terms of the transition and what that's going to be like and it really probably didn't even hit me until the thesis was coming to an end because all you focus is on finishing that thesis and making sure it's done getting through the fiver but I think what was really nice is whilst on uni and I know about some of the unis probably do this as well as helping you try and get prepared for it what was really nice was the centre that I was in and I wasn't looking for applying for a job straight away as and when the job came up because I knew that I was going to
即使当我选择实习时，那是在第二年，我知道那将是我的最后一次实习，但在过渡方面以及那将是什么样子，我并没有意识到。直到论文即将结束时，它才真正击中我，因为你所有的注意力都集中在完成那篇论文上，确保它完成，通过答辩。但我认为非常棒的是，在大学期间，我知道有些大学可能也会这样做，帮助你做好准备，非常棒的是我所在的中心。我并没有立即寻找工作，因为我知道我将
have an extended summer but I thought oh I'll wait until more the summer months before I start looking because who's going to hold a job for me for 10 months or nine months? I said, no, they'll want someone now. But a job came up. My supervisor really encouraged me to go for it. I went for it. I was very happy and very honored to be offered that job. And it was through speaking with them about what that's going to look like for when I come.
有一个延长的暑假，但我心想“哦，我会等到夏天快结束时再开始寻找，因为谁会为我保留一份工作10个月或9个月？”我说，“不，他们现在就需要人。”但一份工作出现了。我的督导真的鼓励我去申请。我申请了。我非常高兴和荣幸能得到那份工作。正是通过与他们交谈，了解当我来的时候那会是什么样子。
Like what sort of support have I got in place? What can I sort of expect? Both in terms terms of the induction but what my role will be and because I'm coming in as the only clinical psychologist there five days a week we do have other people like I said we have someone here who's two days someone here's one day but I will be the one who's there five days and what that's going to look like what my responsibilities would be but how are they going to help and support me into that and I was like I said because I was already in the organization it was really nice that the organization where I was at that center started to prepare me through the support with all the staff and then meeting the new teams very gradually and then starting
比如我有什么样的支持？我可以期待什么？无论是入职培训方面，还是我的角色将是什么。因为我作为那里唯一的临床心理学家，每周五天都在那里。我们确实有其他人，就像我说的，我们这里有人每周两天，有人每周一天，但我将是那个每周五天都在那里的人。那会是什么样子，我的职责是什么，他们将如何帮助和支持我进入这个角色？就像我说的，因为我已经在这个组织里了，非常棒的是，我所在的那个中心的组织开始通过所有员工的支持来准备我，然后逐渐见到新的团队，然后开始
with a really nice induction where I went up to the original centre in Edinburgh. And it's been really nice. And I have felt through the support and through the open channels of having questions and then being able to just get ideas across and learn a bit more, that's been a really nice transition period rather than just having applied for a job,
一个非常好的入职培训，我去了爱丁堡的原始中心。这真的很好。通过支持，通过拥有提问的开放渠道，然后能够交流想法并学习更多，这是一个非常好的过渡期，而不是仅仅申请了一份工作，
not really knowing what to expect and then bump, you start. It's been a really gentle period of where you where I've been learning and able to ask and find out and a really nice gentle induction yeah and I think the right service will wait for the right applicant as well so I know that you wanted to go off traveling and spend some time really decompressing from training after it finished and that was something that it would have been very important to me. Apart from when I qualified, there were no jobs.
不知道会发生什么，然后砰的一声，你就开始了。这是一个非常温和的时期，我在学习，能够提问和发现，一个非常好的温和的入职培训。是的，我认为合适的服务会等待合适的申请人。我知道你想去旅行，在培训结束后花点时间真正放松一下，这对我来说非常重要。除了我获得资格的时候，那时没有工作。
And I qualified in 2011. It was just kind of coming to the back end of the recession, really. Started in 2008, which was my first year of training. It meant that I had no job from when I finished in September until December. and, you know, ate a lot of lentils and walked a lot of places and tried to minimize my life a little bit. But it gave me a wonderful time to consolidate what I'd learned and have some downtime. And I've always been a keen traveler. I would have liked to have done some traveling, but I had no money around and I had a mortgage to pay for. So yeah, I think ideally,
我在2011年获得资格。那正好是经济衰退的尾声。2008年开始，那是我培训的第一年。这意味着从九月结束到十二月，我没有工作。而且，你知道，吃了很多扁豆，走了很多地方，试图稍微精简我的生活。但这给了我一段美好的时间来巩固我所学的知识，并获得一些休息时间。我一直是一个热衷于旅行的人。我本来想去旅行，但我没有钱，而且我还要付抵押贷款。所以是的，我认为理想情况下，
I'd always say try and have a bit of time where you can just be you and not have to kind of worry. And also, if you can afford to not work for a little bit you're not using any annual leave so it's kind of a really nice chance to have a bit more of an extended break and when I was in my second year this first placement of my second year someone in the year above got a job in pediatrics to start the next year but this had a whole year to go and at the time it felt like wow but actually if the right job comes up why not apply and figure out the details later but that's actually incredibly supportive and especially if you're moving if you've got a an unconditional job offer it's kind of quite helpful to be able to show mortgage lenders and stuff as well you're like you're gonna be sorted you're gonna be working and you're gonna be working at this level so yeah I really I really
我总是说，试着有一点时间，你可以只是你自己，而不必担心。而且，如果你负担得起暂时不工作，你就不需要使用任何年假，所以这是一个获得更长假期的好机会。当我在第二年时，我第二年的第一次实习，高年级的一个人在儿科找到了一份工作，要在下一年开始，但这还有整整一年。当时感觉“哇”，但实际上，如果合适的工作出现，为什么不申请并稍后再弄清楚细节呢？但这实际上是非常支持的，特别是如果你要搬家，如果你有一个无条件的工作录用通知，这对于向抵押贷款机构展示也很有帮助，你就像“你会没事的，你会工作的，你会达到这个水平”。所以是的，我真的真的
love that the job spoke to you and you know you just went for it I honestly really connect with so many things that you've said there I mean first and foremost I knew going into the doctorate that it was going to be such an incredibly tough three years I mean it's a doctor it's not going to be easy so I already planned in advance and like right I need some time off after that so I had that it was going to be such an incredibly tough three years. I mean, it's a doctorate. It's not going to be easy. So I already planned in advance, being like, right, I need some time off after that. So I had to put money away each month, even just a little bit, over the three years to cover any expenses that I would need
喜欢那份工作吸引你的方式，你知道，你只是去争取了。我真的与你所说的很多事情产生了共鸣。我的意思是，首先，在进入博士课程时，我就知道这将是极其艰难的三年。我的意思是，这是博士学位，不会很容易。所以我已经提前计划好了，就像“好吧，我需要在之后休假”。所以我必须在三年里每个月存钱，哪怕只是一点点，以支付我需要的任何费用，
to have a month of not being paid. Ideally, I would have loved to have gone for longer, but you know, money and time, that's not always going to be possible. But I saved all of my annual leave as well for that rest of the year so then i had two months off and it was it was just what i needed because i think that break like i said not only just consolidating but allowing your mind and your body to just actually completely and utterly switch off and relax because it without even
以度过一个月没有收入的时间。理想情况下，我希望能去更久，但你知道，金钱和时间，那并不总是可能的。我也存下了我所有的年假，为了那一年的剩余时间，所以我休了两个月，这正是我所需要的。因为我认为那种休息，就像我说的，不仅是巩固，而且是让你的思想和身体真正彻底地关闭和放松。因为如果没有
consciously being aware of it you it's been such an anxiety and intense time, particularly when you're going through all, you think it's over when you hand your thesis in, and then you're, oh no, I've got the Viber coming up now. And then after the Viber, you're like, oh no, now I've got all of this paperwork that I need to do by certain days, and then I need to apply for the HCPC to make sure that when I start work, I'm actually at the recognized and accredited level.
有意识地意识到这一点，这一直是一个焦虑和紧张的时期，特别是当你经历这一切时，你以为交了论文就结束了，然后你，“哦不，我现在要进行答辩了”。答辩之后，你，“哦不，现在我有所有这些文书工作需要在特定日期前完成，然后我需要向 HCPC 申请，以确保当我开始工作时，我确实处于认可和认证的水平。”
So there's a lot of things that are still there bubbling under so that time apart off was so needed and I think you're right I mean you want to be able to apply for something that's the right job and if it's the right job they will wait for you and it wasn't just me on my course there was lots of people on our course that had applied for jobs and they were waiting for them but it must have felt so different for you back in 2011 than when the jobs went there because there was so many jobs coming up i mean i were the year before thinking oh look at all these jobs in in london which is where i was moving back to there'll be none they'll all go and there'll be none left and there was always pages and pages and pages of jobs. So it never felt, I never felt worried that I wouldn't get one, if that sounds strange.
所以有很多事情还在酝酿中，所以那段休息时间太必要了。而且我认为你是对的，我的意思是，你想要能够申请一份合适的工作，如果它是合适的工作，他们会等你。而且不仅仅是我那届，我们课程上很多人都申请了工作，他们都在等他们。但对于2011年的你来说，一定感觉和工作机会很多的时候非常不同。我的意思是，我在前一年想“哦，看看伦敦的所有这些工作”，那是我要搬回的地方，“不会有工作了，它们都会被抢光，一个都不会剩下”。但总是有页数众多的工作。所以我从来没有担心过我找不到工作，如果这听起来很奇怪的话。
But it must have felt strange back in 2017 for you. Yeah, and actually my final placements in my final year were systemic and then psychodynamic, both in adult services. I think there was some lifespan work in my systemic service. But when I qualified, there was 16 of us when we qualified because someone from the cohort above had dropped down after having a baby but of those 16 people how many people do you think had jobs David when the course finished oh so if I was going to say now I'd probably say all 16 but if I think about back in 2017 and from what you've said, let's go for five? Three.
但对于2017年的你来说，那一定感觉很奇怪。是的，实际上我在最后一年最后的实习是系统性的，然后是心理动力学的，都是在成人服务中。我想我的系统性服务中也有一些生命周期的工作。但当我获得资格时，我们获得资格时有16个人，因为高年级的一个人在生完孩子后降级了。但大卫，你认为这16个人中有多少人在课程结束时有工作？哦，如果我现在要说，我可能会说全部16个。但如果我回想2017年，根据你所说的，我们猜五个？三个。
Three? Oh, wow. Okay, it's even less. Wow. Three. And so it was just really hard going. And it wasn't a case of, oh, there's this job that's come up in an area that is a bit of me.
三个？哦，哇。好吧，甚至更少。哇。三个。所以这真的很难。而且这不是“哦，有一个工作出现在我喜欢的领域”的情况。
It was this job has come up I'm applying for it it doesn't matter what it is and I probably felt like CAMHS was a bit of my weakness really I'd done honorary work as a in the brownies and I was I was wise owl in the brownies and so I'd worked with children in a in a fun capacity and then I did placement as an assistant psychologist in a youth prison I'm I'm not cool enough to work in a youth prison is what I've learned and then I did a lifespan intellectual disabilities placement on training and a CAMHS placement and then I did some some work with children's and children and families during the systemic but I definitely felt like it's weird because listening back to myself now,
而是“这份工作出现了，我正在申请它，它是什么并不重要”。我可能觉得 CAMHS（儿童与青少年心理健康服务）有点是我的弱点。我在布朗尼（Brownies）做过荣誉工作，我是布朗尼里的“智者猫头鹰”，所以我以一种有趣的方式与孩子们一起工作过。然后我作为助理心理学家在青少年监狱实习。我学到的是，我没有酷到可以在青少年监狱工作。然后我在培训中做了生命周期智力障碍实习和 CAMHS 实习，然后我在系统性实习期间做了一些与儿童和家庭相关的工作。但我绝对觉得这很奇怪，因为现在回听我自己，
I'm like, you were really experienced with children. But you know what we tell ourselves? I was like, oh, this is my Achilles heel. This is something that I'm not that good at. But listening to myself now, I can see why my first qualified job was in camps. You almost don't realise how good you are or what, I don't know, what you've got going for you, what your assets are. I think probably until you pass by. So I genuinely, as I reflect on it now, which sounds a bit silly, I felt like it was really fluky that I'd managed to get this job
我心想，“你对孩子非常有经验”。但你知道我们对自己说什么吗？我当时想，“哦，这是我的阿喀琉斯之踵。这是我不擅长的事情。”但现在回听我自己，我能明白为什么我的第一份合格工作是在 CAMHS。你几乎没有意识到你有多好，或者，我不知道，你有什么优势，你的资产是什么。我想可能直到你通过了。所以我真诚地，正如我现在反思的那样，这听起来有点傻，我觉得我能得到这份工作真是太幸运了，
in Birmingham so I was having to commute 24 miles of each way which was not ideal but I know I would not have applied for that job if if it hadn't been for the circumstances I started that at the start of December 2011 and it was amazing I was working in an award-winning service for patient safety so it taught me just really robust practices for operating a really safe, brilliant, compassionate service but also because at the time it was using the choice and partnership approach kappa it taught me about job planning and managing my own time and not taking on more than I meant to and but also doing your fair bit and making sure that you are you know doing what you're supposed to be doing and and my manager and my supervisor and all of the team were just incredible.
在伯明翰，所以我不得不每天往返24英里，这并不理想。但我知道，如果不是因为当时的情况，我不会申请那份工作。我在2011年12月初开始了那份工作，这太棒了。我在一个屡获殊荣的患者安全服务机构工作，所以它教会了我非常稳健的实践，以运营一个真正安全、出色、富有同情心的服务。而且因为当时它使用的是选择与伙伴关系方法（CAPA），它教会了我工作规划和管理我自己的时间，不承担超出我能力的责任，但也尽到我的本分，确保你，你知道，做你该做的事。我的经理、我的督导和整个团队都太不可思议了。
And actually, in terms of the transition, I thought I needed kid gloves. I thought they would say, well, because you're newly qualified, we're going to do this. We're going to do that. They were like, we've been waiting for someone in this role for so long. You're qualified. Like, here's, you know, do it. We trust you. Get on with it.
事实上，关于过渡期，我原以为需要小心翼翼地对待。我以为他们会说，因为你是刚取得资格，所以我们要这样做，我们要那样做。但他们却说，我们在这个职位上等了太久了，你已经具备了资格，所以，你知道的，去做吧，我们信任你，放手去做。
And that was actually really empowering. I don't know what your experience of that is like. yeah basically in a nutshell I'm delighted and I would not be the same clinician now had I not got that job and it all worked out beautifully and I was able to afford that bit of time off it's a very long chunk that I've just said but I hope it kind of resonated with you it really does the thing that really resonated was about that starting that role and actually whilst it's going to be for me it's been a really nice sort of gentle introduction and yes there are certain things that they said oh and we would like you to be doing this and we want you to be in this giving you a bit of time to set it in it's also nice hearing already straight away and then there's so compassion
这真的让我感到很有力量。不知道你的经历是怎样的。简而言之，我非常高兴，如果我没有得到那份工作，我现在就不会是现在的临床医生了。一切都进展得非常顺利，我也负担得起那段休息时间。我刚才说了一大段话，但我希望这能引起你的共鸣。确实引起了共鸣，最让我感触的是关于开始那个新角色，虽然对我来说，这是一个非常好的、温和的入门方式，是的，他们确实说了一些“我们希望你做这个，我们希望你参与那个”的话，给了我一些适应的时间，但听到这些也很好，而且他们非常有同情心。
so lovely here because they said we know that you've got the experience we know that you've got these skills we know that you can do it do it do it but not wanting to put that huge pressure on you and they sounded maybe like that was for you as well they wanted to do that they didn't want you to feel that oh completely overwhelmed or overworked and it's exactly what it's been like here which is nice because it's not only they know and they're supporting your own belief and your skills and you as a clinical psychologist but they're wanting to make sure that you are caring for yourself and you're not pushing yourself to the limits because they care about you yeah and they
这里的人太可爱了，因为他们说我们知道你有经验，我们知道你有这些技能，我们知道你能做到，去做吧，但他们不想给你施加巨大的压力。听起来你可能也是这样，他们想这样做，他们不想让你感到不知所措或过度劳累。这里的情况正是如此，这很好，因为他们不仅了解并支持你的信念、你的技能以及你作为临床心理学家的身份，而且他们还想确保你照顾好自己，不会把自己逼到极限，因为他们关心你。是的，他们
believe in you and hopefully they've met you at interview they like you hopefully you know in the in the certain level i was being interviewed they probably interviewed probably 10 people or something because everybody was desperate for jobs whereas actually when I was in my most recent NHS service sometimes you'd put a band seven out and one person would apply like because there were so many jobs you know and I don't know like if you've got the job, it's because you've met the standard and they think that you're going to be not just a good fit for the clients, but they think that you're going to be a good fit in that team as well. When I've worked on selection panels, actually, sometimes I think about if this person was in my team and I've done this in training
相信你，希望他们在面试时见到你，他们喜欢你。你知道，在某种程度上，我面试时他们可能面试了10个人左右，因为每个人都急于找工作。而实际上，当我在最近的NHS服务部门时，有时你发布一个七级职位的招聘，只有一个人申请，因为工作岗位太多了。我不知道，如果你得到了这份工作，那是因为你达到了标准，他们认为你不仅适合客户，而且认为你也会很适合那个团队。当我在选拔小组工作时，我有时会想，如果这个人进入我的团队会怎样，我在培训时也做过
selection panels too. If this person was in my team, how would I feel if I'd forgotten my wallet and I needed to go and borrow a fiver from them? How, you know, is that something I'd feel comfortable doing? Would it feel okay to have them make me a cup of tea or to offer to make them a cup of tea? How would it feel to say, oh, how was your weekend, David? Like, what are you looking forward to? Or, you know, are you going on any holidays?
选拔小组的工作。如果这个人进入我的团队，如果我忘了带钱包，需要向他们借五英镑，我会感觉如何？你知道，这会是我觉得舒服的事情吗？让他们给我泡杯茶，或者主动提出给他们泡杯茶，感觉会好吗？问一句“大卫，你的周末过得怎么样？”或者“你在期待什么？”或者“你要去度假吗？”会是什么感觉？
You've really got to think about this being not just clinical work, but kind of, and if someone's got kind of an autism diagnosis and they might be like, I don't want any of that. Like, you can make a job what you need to have for you. But for me, they chose me, you know. They chose Marianne as well as a psychologist in it it's about that connection with them isn't it you want to be able to have that connection and to have that really nice team dynamic and yes that's that i guess that's really that's about
你真的必须考虑到这不仅仅是临床工作，而且，如果有人被诊断出患有自闭症，他们可能会说，我不想要这些。你可以根据自己的需要来调整工作。但对我来说，他们选择了我，你知道，他们选择了玛丽安作为心理学家。这关乎与他们的联系，不是吗？你想要能够建立那种联系，拥有那种非常好的团队活力，是的，我想这就是关于
having the choice i guess for an interview and feeling that they do want you and hearing it as well like they're so they've been ever since the i found out about the the um job offer it's been about oh we can't wait for you to start we're so looking forward to you to start um i had the other sense and being that we're gonna really miss you we're so they're gonna have such an amazing person that's joining their team and it just really builds like you said that a belief in you that actually you are you are good enough for it it was meant to be in a way if you think about that way then you do deserve it and it's really nice it really is a positive feeling rather than going in with all those question marks being like didn't I really
拥有选择权，我想对于面试来说，感觉到他们确实想要你，并且听到这些，就像自从我得知工作录用通知以来，他们一直说“我们迫不及待地想让你开始，我们非常期待你的加入”。我有另一种感觉，那就是“我们会非常想念你，他们会迎来一个如此出色的人加入他们的团队”，这真的建立起像你所说的对你的信念，实际上你确实足够胜任。从某种意义上说，这是命中注定的，如果你这样想，那么你确实应得的。这真的很好，这确实是一种积极的感觉，而不是带着所有那些问号进去，想着我真的
operate you've had all that really nice build-up yeah absolutely and the imposter syndrome is going to be rampant but you kind of want it to be because you don't want to be going in as arrogant and renegade. actually to the children's hospital and work on the kind of advice and support line that also did all the assessments for all of CAMHS for the whole of Birmingham and was exciting. It was daunting, but I learned a lot from the experts there. So the emergency response and assessment team were based in the same office. And so I'd be able to hear all of their kind of decision making but one of my jobs was to talk to either referrers or kind of parents and sometimes young people on the phone to think about whether an assessment was going to be the right thing to do and then I'd get stacks of referrals coming in throughout that point of the day that I was there. And I would need to make a clinical decision
运作得很好，你经历了所有那些非常好的铺垫。是的，绝对是这样，冒名顶替综合症会很猖獗，但你反而希望它存在，因为你不想以傲慢和叛逆的姿态进入。实际上，在儿童医院从事咨询和支持热线工作，同时也为伯明翰整个地区的CAMHS进行所有评估，这很令人兴奋。这很令人生畏，但我从那里的专家身上学到了很多。所以紧急响应和评估小组在同一个办公室办公，所以我能够听到他们所有的决策过程。但我的工作之一是与转诊医生或家长，有时是年轻人通电话，考虑评估是否是正确的做法，然后我会在一天中的那个时间点收到堆积如山的转诊。我需要做出临床决定
about what to do with that referral, whether it met clinical need for service, whether we'd step it up to the emergency response assessment, whether we'd step it down, whether we'd think about kind of doing an assessment to think about what needs there might be. And it's that clinical responsibility. It's that actually I can decide this all by myself. That was quite hard. And it takes growing into that. But what somebody said to me at the time was, it's okay. You just make your decision.
关于如何处理那个转诊，它是否满足服务的临床需求，我们是否将其升级到紧急响应评估，我们是否将其降级，我们是否考虑进行评估以思考可能存在什么需求。这就是临床责任。实际上我可以完全自己决定。这相当困难，需要时间去成长。但当时有人对我说，没关系，你只需做出你的决定。
You say what your decision is. And in those days, I was writing it all. And you evidence the information that has helped you to make that decision. And I still do that now. And even if we're looking at risk, you're thinking, actually, I don't think this person needs admission at this time because of this, that and the other. And to mitigate this risk, I'm recommending and have implemented this, that and the other. And it's just that, you know, if you're in a court of law and you find yourself having to speak to your honour, you just need to be able to evidence the decision you've made and why. Yeah, and I think that's something that's going to be, like with anything, it's going to be time in the role
你说出你的决定是什么。在那些日子里，我把一切都写下来。你证明了帮助你做出那个决定的信息。我现在仍然这样做。即使我们在审视风险，你也会想，实际上，我不认为这个人此时需要入院，因为这个、那个和那个原因。为了减轻这种风险，我建议并实施了这个、那个和那个。这只是，你知道，如果你在法庭上，发现自己必须对法官说话，你只需要能够证明你所做的决定以及原因。是的，我认为这是随着时间的推移，就像任何事情一样，在职位上
and building that sort of belief and that trust in yourself. And I know that that's going to be the art of that here as well and all the different types of responsibilities that I'll have. And one of them is about referrals. When it comes to being like, we think it it worries the psychology or do we think that actually we're going to ask for it just to be sort of like active waiting or monitoring and we'll see if that happens or it might be like allocating to different people here who sees them and it's there's a lot there and i think i am fully aware that my imposter syndrome
建立那种信念和对自己的信任。我知道这将是这里的艺术，以及我将拥有的所有不同类型的责任。其中之一是关于转诊。当涉及到“我们认为这是否让心理学部门担心，或者我们认为实际上我们要要求它只是为了某种积极的等待或监测，我们会看看是否会发生这种情况”，或者可能是分配给这里不同的人来看待他们，这里有很多内容。我想我完全意识到我的冒名顶替综合症
is going to jump out it's jumped out to me the whole last three years and probably and actually well before that as well when i was just trying to gain experience it's something that's never going to leave i don't think and i think that's a healthy way of having that because like you said you don't want to come in and you i don't think it's you ever want to have been like i know everything because that's never going to be true and i really enjoyed a postgraduate conference that we went to at the doctorate, the uni where I did the doctorate at. And it was a clinical psychologist who'd been qualified, I think, 20 years. And they said, I still feel like I'm an imposter here.
会跳出来。过去三年它一直困扰着我，可能还有更早之前，当我只是试图获得经验时。我认为这是一种永远不会消失的东西，而且我认为这是一种健康的拥有方式，因为就像你说的，你不想以“我知道一切”的姿态进入，因为那永远不会是真的。我真的很喜欢我们在博士学位期间参加的研究生会议，就是我攻读博士学位的大学。有一位已经获得资格大约20年的临床心理学家说，我仍然觉得我在这里是个冒名顶替者。
It doesn't leave. And it was so nice and quite warm to hear that. It was like, oh, good. So it's not just us it is going to still continue but then that's the motivation i guess and the drive just to continue and always wanting to be open to learning more and and learning from others and that's what i'd love working in an mdt so like this this um that i'm in now this is an mdt within maggie's but also we're linked with the
它不会离开。听到这个感觉真好，也很温暖。就像是，哦，太好了，所以不仅仅是我们。它确实会继续存在，但我想这就是动力和驱动力，去继续前进，总是想要保持开放的心态去学习更多，并向他人学习。这就是我喜欢在多学科团队（MDT）工作的原因，就像我现在所在的这个，这是玛吉中心内的一个多学科团队，但我们也与
mdts within the hospitals and i love that because actually gaining all the different skills experiences perspectives of others can only just make our work better yeah so important and as you're talking i caught sight of my my trophy because recently the podcast has won an award as best best science and technology podcast 2024. And I think if you're struggling with imposter syndrome, just make yourself a trophy. Because I love having this trophy. I might make myself one for best clinical psychologist 2024. You can be 2025.
医院内的多学科团队有联系，我喜欢这一点，因为实际上获得他人所有不同的技能、经验和观点只会让我们的工作更好。是的，这太重要了。当你说话时，我看到了我的奖杯，因为最近这个播客赢得了2024年最佳科学技术播客奖。我想如果你正在与冒名顶替综合症作斗争，就给自己做一个奖杯。因为我喜欢拥有这个奖杯。我可能会给自己做一个2024年最佳临床心理学家奖。你可以是2025年的。
We'll let you do it for a year first. And then you can be 2025. Well, congratulations, first of festival uh that's really good but that's actually a really nice way of getting out of trying to manage that imposter syndrome is something that they told they actually encouraged us to do it back when i was in talking therapies but it has been something that's actually been quite a reg not not regular isn't that every week but quite frequent within the year of different services i've worked in is whenever anyone leaves you any feedback take it and pop it in like a little folder and then when you're
我们会让你先做一年。然后你可以是2025年的。好吧，首先恭喜你，这真的很好。但这实际上是一种摆脱试图管理那种冒名顶替综合症的非常好的方法。这是他们告诉我们的，实际上当我在谈话疗法工作时，他们鼓励我们这样做。但这确实是我工作过的不同服务部门中一年内相当频繁的事情，就是每当有人离开时，给你任何反馈，都要接受它并把它放进一个小文件夹里，然后当你
having a bad day and you're really doubting yourself go back to that and actually look at what people have said and actually it really is quite a nice self-compassionate thing to do as well i've just been able to manage that and that it's okay that we're having a day but it but let's not listen to all them thoughts look at all of this look at these experiences of actually where you are enough you are doing well and you do know what you're doing absolutely i have one as well and i call it the smile file so if you ever need to just like you know feel a little bit better about yourself then you know you have a dig into the smile file. There's actually an episode that's coming out that people will already have been able to listen to on imposter syndrome.
度过糟糕的一天，真的在怀疑自己时，回到那个文件夹，看看人们说了什么。实际上，这确实是一种非常好的自我同情的事情。我刚刚能够管理好这一点，并且意识到我们偶尔度过糟糕的一天也没关系，但让我们不要听信所有那些想法，看看所有这些，看看这些你表现得足够好、做得很好、并且知道自己在做什么的经历。绝对的，我也有一个，我称之为“微笑档案”。所以如果你需要感觉好一点，那么你知道，你可以去翻翻“微笑档案”。实际上有一集关于冒名顶替综合症的节目即将播出，人们已经可以收听了。
Details on screen for that. But if you search for the podcast or wherever you're listening or watching, you'll be able to find that episode. I also heard you say that you're a qualified PWP. There is an episode that people will have been able to listen to with Ben Olofsson, where we're talking about what a PWP is, how you train as one, you know, all of that jazz. So just another little, you know, it's what I've learned as a podcaster, you have to keep, you know, talking about all your other stuff as well. One of the key differences, I think, when you go from trainee life to qualified life is that certainly from my experience I went from a really supportive tight-knit cohort and a varied week went from you know a Monday and a
屏幕上有详细信息。但如果你搜索这个播客，或者无论你在哪里收听或观看，你都能找到那一集。我还听到你说你是一名合格的PWP（心理健康从业者）。有一集人们可以收听，是关于本·奥洛夫森的，我们谈论了什么是PWP，你如何接受培训，你知道，所有这些。所以这只是另一个小小的，你知道，这是我作为播客主持人学到的，你必须不断地谈论你所有的其他事情。我认为，当你从实习生生活转变为合格生活时，关键区别之一是，当然根据我的经验，我从一个非常支持、紧密团结的群体中走出来，一周的时间很丰富，你知道，周一和
Friday were usually academic days and then I had like a Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, placement days. And so there was that really nice cushioning of weekend, trainee, learning, placement, trainee, learning or study day, and depending on what stages of the career I was at. I couldn't really believe it when I started qualified life and every day I was in a split post when I first qualified but every day I was working for five days a week and I was having to pay for my own fuels and it was hard it was a hard adjustment so I missed my cohort and I couldn't quite believe I had to do it every day. Is there anything you miss or kind of found surprising about moving? I was also worse off because I was having to pay for my fuel and because I only went from band six to band seven and I then had
周五通常是学术日，然后我有周二、周三、周四作为实习日。所以有周末、实习生、学习、实习、实习生、学习或学习日的缓冲，取决于我处于职业生涯的哪个阶段。当我开始合格生活时，我简直不敢相信，每天我都在一个分职岗位上，但我每天都在工作，一周五天，我不得不自己支付燃料费，这很难，这是一个艰难的调整。所以我怀念我的群体，我简直不敢相信我必须每天都这样做。有什么你怀念的，或者在搬迁过程中感到惊讶的事情吗？我也过得更糟了，因为我不得不支付燃料费，而且因为我只是从六级升到了七级，然后我不得不
to start paying council tax. I was worse off when I qualified than when I was a trainee. But yeah, how about you? Is there anything you miss or anything that kind of was different than you expected? Yeah, there's been quite a few different things that I do miss. And like with you, I really miss my cohort. You know, our cohort started off with 33. We didn't build down in the final year to 28. A few there, a few on the cohort had babies. So we have
开始支付市政税。我获得资格后比做实习生时过得更糟。但是，你呢？有什么你怀念的，或者有什么与你预期的不同吗？是的，确实有几件不同的事情我怀念。和你一样，我真的很怀念我的群体。你知道，我们的群体开始时有33人。我们在最后一年没有减少到28人。那里有几个人，群体里有几个人生了孩子。所以我们有
a i think there's four or five babies from our cohort now already but i really miss just being able to connect with them and see them very regularly just having someone else you can just bounce to so quickly so you just effort this and just everyone's around and it fell at that tight tight sort of cohort and yes with such a big group you do have the little groups as well of where you feel more closer to but i think i think we all probably really miss that of just having everyone at an arm's length i do feel very lucky that i've had a very supportive math placement very supportive current first qualified role so i think that's really nice to transition to and have that little bit of a um consistency but another thing that i do really miss is um study
我想我们的群体现在已经有四五个孩子了，但我真的很怀念能够与他们联系并经常见到他们。只要有其他人你可以很快地交流，所以你只是……每个人都在身边，感觉就像那个紧密的群体。是的，对于这么大的群体，你确实也有更亲近的小团体，但我认为我们可能都非常怀念那种每个人都触手可及的感觉。我确实感到非常幸运，我有一个非常支持的实习安置，非常支持目前的第一个合格职位，所以我认为过渡到这里并拥有那一点点一致性真的很好。但另一件我确实非常怀念的事情是……学习
days i know i'm not going to get them three days again i loved it i was like oh i could i could get up at like and i could get up at six in the morning if i wanted to finish by 11 and oh got the rest of the day it's great um so actually moving to five days a week is actually quite a lot and as with you about the commute I mean I've lived in Southampton where I've had my car and I've been driving into placement which is always quite nice it gets your attention going
日。我知道我再也不会有那三天了。我喜欢它，我当时想，哦，我可以，如果我想在11点完成，我可以早上6点起床，哦，剩下的时间都是我的，太棒了。所以实际上转为一周五天工作制确实很多。和你一样，关于通勤，我的意思是，我住在南安普敦，我有车，我开车去实习，这总是很好，它能让你的注意力集中
on your way there listen to some music not really that stressful because there wasn't traffic well it didn't tend to be that bad in London getting used to theutes getting used to the armpits in your face again traveling in rush hour it's yeah that's a big adjustment and i already i've already altered that and i've got up early to set off early and also have a nice little walk before
在去那里的路上，听听音乐，压力并不大，因为没有交通堵塞，好吧，在伦敦往往没那么糟糕。习惯通勤，再次习惯在高峰时段旅行时腋下对着脸，是的，这是一个很大的调整。我已经改变了这一点，我早起早出发，在
i come in so that i'm not feeling so oh before i walk through the door and so that's been an adjustment the commute the day that the five days a week which has been years since I've done five days because even before the doctor I was on gym four days the cohort and actually I say this and I've always warned like my family and friends and if I ever start talking about this again say no but I actually do really quite miss a bit the research bit as well because you know it's really nice to have the varied role there and yes the thesis is really hard and and stressful but it's also nice to have that little bit of time where you know you've got that time just for the research where you're not having to just have your clinical head on oh yeah several things i do miss yeah um hopefully there's there's lots of benefits to being qualified as well you know it's okay to
我进来之前也有一段很好的小散步，这样我就不会感觉那么……在走进门之前。所以这是一个调整，通勤，一周五天的工作，因为我已经好几年没做过五天了，因为即使在博士学位之前，我也只是做四天。群体，实际上我这么说，我总是警告我的家人和朋友，如果我再次开始谈论这个，就说不。但我实际上确实非常怀念研究部分，因为你知道，拥有多样化的角色真的很好。是的，论文确实很难，而且压力很大，但拥有那一点点时间，你知道你有专门用于研究的时间，而不必一直戴着临床医生的帽子，这也很不错。哦，是的，有几件事我确实怀念。是的，嗯，希望作为合格人员也有很多好处，你知道，
have both of those things it's okay to like where you're at but also miss miss aspects of previous important stages of your life you know so i was reflecting on this the other day I wish I'd really connected to the the last moment that all 15 of us all 16 of us would ever be in a room together and I don't think I really did and even at graduation that didn't happen because one person had had to kind of redo a year so we didn't have that then now people have kind of moved as as lives do someone's moved internationally i don't think we're ever all going to be together again and maybe some people wouldn't even want to i'd be up for it i'd be up for it but i just wish i'd wish i'd connected more i think it's all such a rush isn't it in the in the last few weeks where you're where you're vibrant where
拥有这两者都没关系。喜欢你所处的位置，但也怀念你生命中以前重要阶段的某些方面，这没关系。你知道，前几天我正在反思这一点，我希望我真的与我们15个人、16个人最后一次聚在一起的时刻建立了联系，我不认为我真的做到了。即使在毕业典礼上也没有发生，因为有一个人不得不重读一年，所以我们当时没有那样。现在人们已经搬走了，就像生活常态一样，有人搬到了国际上，我不认为我们还会再聚在一起。也许有些人甚至不想，我会愿意的，我会愿意的，但我只是希望我能多建立一些联系。我认为这一切都太匆忙了，不是吗？在最后几周，当你充满活力，当你
you're doing your revisions where you're perhaps going to last minute catch up study things and but before you know it you're done and I don't I just I don't think we got a photo of us all together on our last day like I wish I'd been more mindful of that so maybe someone listening to this will be like yeah that is significant that is important I would like to really plan a thing and maybe get someone to make sure they're taking photos and I don't think we really did that yeah no that is actually really nice to think about I mean we did have a photo on our last day but not everyone was able to attend so actually the last time we were
正在做复习，当你可能在做最后一分钟的补习学习时，但在你意识到之前，你就完成了。我只是，我不认为我们在最后一天拍了一张我们所有人在一起的照片，我希望我当时能更注意这一点。所以也许听这个的人会想，是的，这很有意义，这很重要，我真的很想计划一件事，也许找个人确保他们拍了照片，我不认为我们真的那样做了。是的，不，想到这一点真的很好。我的意思是，我们在最后一天确实有一张照片，但不是每个人都能参加。所以实际上我们最后一次
all in a room i don't know when that was and that's sad to think about that actually but then life happens and people can't always be there but it would have been nice to maybe think about that because i think once survivor happened it was like i think we've only got two more days together it was the whole cohort and i actually wish maybe we maybe we've been able to do a few more things all together over the three years. I look back and think, whilst that's a nice reflection to have also,
都在一个房间里，我不知道那是什么时候，想到这一点很伤感。但生活就是这样，人们并不总是能在那里，但如果能考虑到这一点可能会很好，因为我认为一旦生存下来，就像是，我想我们在一起只剩下两天了，那是整个群体。我实际上希望也许我们能在三年里多做一些大家在一起的事情。我回顾过去，认为，虽然这是一个很好的反思，但
people do have busy lives, people work commutes in long ways as well. So that's again, not always possible, but that's why it's also nice to look back and think, I'm going to miss the cohort. I'm going to miss the close-knit groups, but I'm also really glad that we've formed and we've had that time together.
人们确实有忙碌的生活，人们通勤的路程也很长。所以这再次说明，并不总是可能的，但这就是为什么回顾过去并认为“我会怀念这个群体，我会怀念那些紧密的团体，但我也非常高兴我们组建了它，并且我们在一起度过了那段时光”也很好。
We will still keep in contact it won't be the same but we still will and it's exciting for this new role we're all quite we're all ready we're all there we're all now being this is what we've worked for this is what we dreamed of and we're here now let's enjoy it because yes there's things that we'll miss but there's so many more exciting opportunities to look forward to yeah and you get to be really excited and proud of your cohort as they grow in their careers as well you know people will start to go oh i've got an interview for an 8a or i've got an interview for an 8b or 8c like though and beyond or you know they will be like well you've left the nhs how is that for you to you know to give up
我们仍然会保持联系，虽然不会和以前一样，但我们仍然会。对于这个新角色，我们都很兴奋，我们都准备好了，我们都在那里，我们现在正在成为……这就是我们为之努力的，这就是我们梦想的，我们现在就在这里，让我们享受它吧。因为是的，有些事情我们会怀念，但还有更多令人兴奋的机会值得期待。是的，当你看着你的群体在职业生涯中成长时，你也会感到非常兴奋和自豪。你知道，人们会开始说“我得到了一个8a职位的面试”或者“我得到了一个8b或8c职位的面试”，诸如此类，甚至更远。或者你知道，他们会说“好吧，你离开了NHS，放弃了
your nhs pension and move somewhere different like you will still be sort of support and you know celebration for each other which is really really nice. Yeah and it's nice to actually hear of all the different roles we went on because that's one of the things I think we were talking about within our last few weeks together where is everyone going what's everyone doing some people who were talking about all the different sort of travel plans or the time off then the jobs we were going into the potential sorts of things that we could maybe look forward to training in later and that's definitely things that i've got is moving forward i've got some goals i know what i want to still be working towards but i'm really allowing myself the time to settle into this role learn what it's like to be a full-time qualified clinical psychologist
你的NHS养老金并搬到不同的地方，这对你来说怎么样？”你们仍然会以某种方式相互支持和庆祝，这真的非常好。是的，听到我们去的所有不同角色真的很好，因为我认为这是我们在最后几周在一起时谈论的事情之一，每个人要去哪里，每个人在做什么。有些人谈论所有不同的旅行计划或休息时间，然后是我们进入的工作，我们以后可能期待培训的潜在事情。这绝对是我前进的方向，我有目标，我知道我仍然想朝着什么方向努力，但我真的让自己有时间适应这个角色，学习成为一名全职合格的临床心理学家是什么感觉
before I then start thinking, what's the next step? I want to give myself permission to actually just be and then think about what I would like to do. But I know what my goals are already. Absolutely. Good. Well, I might have you back on
在我开始思考下一步之前。我想给自己许可去真正地存在，然后思考我想做什么。但我已经知道我的目标是什么了。绝对的。好的。好吧，我可能会请你回来
to talk about cancer if you're up for that anyway. But just before we finish, and thank you for your time. I know I have a slightly falsely advertised time and I'd keep you for as well because I've been really enjoying our chat. But is there anything that surprised you
谈谈癌症，如果你愿意的话。但在我们结束之前，谢谢你的时间。我知道我稍微虚假宣传了时间，我也想留住你，因为我真的很享受我们的聊天。但有什么让你感到惊讶的吗
about this transition from trainee to qualified life, David? Surprised at how, for me, how seamlessly it seems to go. I don't know why I envisaged it being more tricky but i think because i was i'd had a lot of support to get to this part and having that time off really did help that actually it seems to go really nicely that's personally that's just for mine i don't know what
关于从实习生到合格生活的这种转变，大卫？惊讶于，对我来说，它似乎进行得多么顺利。我不知道为什么我设想它会更棘手，但我认为因为我得到了很多支持才走到这一步，而且那段休息时间确实有帮助，实际上它似乎进行得非常好。这是个人的，那只是我的，我不知道
other experiences that people may have when they've moved but I think having that sort of open mind of you know we'll see how it goes we will we'll take it each day as it comes and for me that was a really nice really nice transition yeah I feel like I want to ask you which countries you traveled to where did you go for your for your little hiatus so I was very lucky because my mom, she travels quite a bit as well. And so she was in the Canary Islands for six weeks. Lucky her. So I was like, please can I come? And so I went to join her and my stepdad for two and a half weeks and just had two and a half weeks of sitting on a beach, doing nothing.
当人们搬迁时，他们可能有什么其他经历。但我认为拥有那种开放的心态，你知道，“我们会看看进展如何，我们会顺其自然”，对我来说，那是一个非常好的、非常好的过渡。是的，我觉得我想问你去了哪些国家，你去了哪里度过你的小假期？所以我非常幸运，因为我妈妈，她也经常旅行。所以她在加那利群岛待了六周。她真幸运。所以我说，请问我可以去吗？所以我去和她以及我的继父待了两周半，只是度过了两周半坐在海滩上，什么都不做。
No emails, no phones or anything like that. It was just so nice to just switch off and then I came back to London for literally 48 hours and then went off to Japan for three weeks which was the most incredible experience completely and for me just such a different culture such a different sort of world and it looked so welcoming so kind absolutely loved it would definitely have already planned to go back again and it was nice to travel around to a few different places and it was the best the best way I could have had to really switch off before coming oh that's that sounds incredible I've never been to Japan actually I
没有电子邮件，没有电话，诸如此类。能够关机真的太好了，然后我回到伦敦待了整整48小时，然后去了日本三周，这是最不可思议的经历。对我来说，这完全是一种不同的文化，一个不同的世界，看起来非常受欢迎，非常友善，绝对喜欢它，肯定已经计划再次回去。能够去几个不同的地方旅行很好，这是我在回来之前真正能够关机的最好、最好的方式。哦，那听起来太不可思议了。我实际上从来没去过日本，我
haven't done it but I'll try and get it on the bucket list. Yeah, I loved what you said, actually, that you always knew you were having this period of downtime. And actually, you saved for that. And it made me reflect upon when I was doing my undergraduate degree, I always knew I was going to save really, really hard and have six months to go backpacking. And when it was hard, when I was having to stay in and do my thesis or prepare for my exams, my housemates actually, for various reasons, had dropped down a year. And so I was the only one in my third year,
还没去过，但我会试着把它列入愿望清单。是的，我喜欢你所说的，实际上，你一直知道你会有这段停机时间。而且实际上，你为此存了钱。这让我反思我读本科时，我一直知道我会非常、非常努力地存钱，然后有六个月的时间去背包旅行。当生活很艰难时，当我不得不待在家里写论文或准备考试时，我的室友实际上因为各种原因降了一年级。所以我是在第三年里唯一的一个，
but I was almost using how amazing it was going to be to be away for six months around the world to spur me through the trickier times and I think that that is something that perhaps people could envisage you know I'm really struggling with that word today but I could really imagine you know using that as a way of managing the stress because you're actually going to get to somewhere really really special where you do get to have that cocktail in a coconut and you know watch the sunset in Thailand or whatever it is that floats your boat like there will be hard times during training there will be hard times during qualified life but it's making sure that you've got good work-life balance to help bolster that i think i couldn't agree more and
但我几乎是在利用环游世界六个月会有多棒来激励我度过更棘手的时期。我认为这可能是人们可以设想的，你知道，我今天真的在和那个词作斗争，但我真的可以想象，你知道，利用这一点作为管理压力的一种方式，因为你实际上要去一个非常、非常特别的地方，在那里你确实可以在椰子里喝鸡尾酒，你知道，在泰国看日落，或者任何让你感到快乐的事情。培训期间会有艰难的时刻，合格生活期间也会有艰难的时刻，但要确保你有良好的工作与生活平衡来帮助支持这一点。我想我不能同意更多，而且
i think that's something i've always tried to do ever since when i worked in cams and it was the sort of work we were helped we were sort of supporting the young people with is we don't always have to have something on all the time it's it's not always going to be a perfect happy great exciting day if you can have things in your week, month, years, to look forward to, it's giving you that motivation. It's giving you that oomph. Yes, it's a tough week. Yes, it's a tough day, but look what I'm going for.
我认为这是我一直试图做的事情，自从我在CAMHS工作以来，这是我们帮助、我们支持年轻人的那种工作，我们并不总是必须一直有事情要做。如果你能在你的周、月、年里有值得期待的事情，那并不总是会是一个完美、快乐、伟大、令人兴奋的一天，它会给你动力。它会给你那种活力。是的，这是一个艰难的一周。是的，这是一个艰难的一天，但看看我正在追求什么。
And that's what really helped me. I mean, I did have a very tough year in the doctorate, the last year particularly, but it was having these things ahead. We've been like, I know what's coming if I head down get this through you can do it we've all got it and we can it's going to be there for us and then look what I've got I've got and that is going to be when I'm just going to feel so relaxed and I've obviously never slept better in those last two months well long may that last because i think this is why i came since i became a mother and then um
这就是真正帮助我的东西。我的意思是，我在博士学位期间确实度过了非常艰难的一年，特别是最后一年，但正是因为有了这些预期的东西。我们一直说，我知道接下来会发生什么，如果我埋头苦干，完成这个，你就能做到，我们都有它，它会为我们存在。然后看看我得到了什么，我得到了……那将是我感到如此放松的时候，我显然在最后两个月里从未睡得更好。好吧，愿那持续下去，因为我认为这就是为什么我自从成为母亲，然后
got into my 40s my sleep i looked back on my sleep in my 20s and i was like oh you just didn't know i don't know how good you had it marianne but yes long may your sleep be marvelous david thank you so much for your time it's going to be incredibly useful for people thinking about transition but also using this as a as a kind of gold nugget to head towards if they are earlier in their career and thank you for having me on we're very honoured to be on your podcast with you and if you do want to have another one just let me know i'm very happy to but yeah i really appreciate it perfect i absolutely will do but yeah wishing, wishing you well with this first year of qualified life. May it be really special. May it be containing.
进入40岁后，我的睡眠……我回顾我20多岁的睡眠，我想，哦，你只是不知道，我不知道你当时有多好，玛丽安。但是的，愿你的睡眠永远美妙。大卫，非常感谢你的时间。这对考虑过渡的人来说将非常有用，但也将其作为一种金块，如果他们处于职业生涯早期，可以朝着这个方向努力。谢谢你邀请我。我们非常荣幸能参加你的播客。如果你想再做一次，就告诉我，我非常乐意。但是的，我真的很感激。完美，我绝对会做的。但是的，祝你在合格生活的第一年一切顺利。愿它非常特别。愿它具有包容性。
May it help you feel clinically competent, but also happy and like, you know, like it's meant to be. And that it feels like it continues to feel like a pleasure to come to work. Oh, thank you very much. I'm sure it will, but thank you. Thank you. Oh, thank you so much to our guest, Dr. David. Dr. Dr. Dr. Dr. David. You did it.
愿它帮助你感到临床胜任，但也感到快乐，就像，你知道，就像它是命中注定的。并且感觉它继续让人感到去工作是一种乐趣。哦，非常感谢。我相信会的，但谢谢你。谢谢。哦，非常感谢我们的嘉宾，大卫博士。大卫博士、博士、博士、博士。你做到了。
You came out the other side. Well done. And thank you for your time. I would love to know what you think to this episode. Please do come and connect with me on socials where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. Please do come and join the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent, which is the exclusive home of Marianne's motivation and mindset sessions, which happen each Friday at nine. If it's your time and you're ready for the next step, you are ready to start imagining that
你从另一边出来了。做得好。谢谢你的时间。我很想知道你对这一集的看法。请务必在社交媒体上与我联系，我在那里到处都是玛丽安·特伦特博士。请务必加入免费的Facebook群组，“有抱负的心理学家社区与玛丽安·特伦特博士”，这是玛丽安的动力和心态课程的独家主页，每周五九点进行。如果时间到了，你准备好迎接下一步了，你准备好开始想象那个
trainee psychologist, that qualified psychologist, that assistant psychologist name badge, then please do consider the Aspiring Psychologist membership. We really do help people to get job interviews, to get job offers, to really get the things they want to happen in their career to happen. We get people onto doctoral courses and we help them to feel supported and to learn important skills along the way too. It starts at just £30 a month with no minimum term. Please do check out the website www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk for more information. Please also consider the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book, the Clinical Psychologist Collective book and the brand new kid on the block, An Autistic Anthology, which is real life stories of people with autism diagnosis talking about their experiences working in mental health.
实习心理学家、合格心理学家、助理心理学家的名字徽章了，那么请考虑“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”。我们确实帮助人们获得工作面试，获得工作录用，真正让人们在职业生涯中想要发生的事情发生。我们让人们进入博士课程，我们也帮助他们感到被支持，并在此过程中学习重要的技能。它每月只需30英镑，没有最低期限。请查看网站www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk了解更多信息。也请考虑《有抱负的心理学家集体》一书，《临床心理学家集体》一书，以及全新的成员，《自闭症选集》，这是患有自闭症诊断的人讲述他们在心理健康领域工作的经历的真实生活故事。
Thank you so much for your time. Thank you from the bottom of my heart for being such a loyal listener or watcher. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
非常感谢你的时间。从心底里感谢你成为如此忠实的听众或观众。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你就会走上合格的道路。这是与玛丽安·特伦特博士合作的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫贾娜，我是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》一书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，并减轻了我的压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be OK. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这个，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。